j'ai perdu mes lunettes
enfin j'ai pas voulu les mettre elles me
font une drôle de tête une tête de
flamme à lunettes
non
oooh petite allumette c'est dangereux y
être coquette au point de n'en faire
qu'à sa tête quand ça peut vous coûter
les yeux je me faut d'ivoire flou je
n'ai pas besoin de lunettes pour mon
bras serrés chanter je préfère garder
les yeux fermés
oh mon petit incendie
laissez-moi cros que vos ab les
déchiqueter rabel dans les recracher en
confettis pour vous embrasser sous une
pluie de confettis
oui allons-y je n'y vois que du feu
en quelques pas seulement je te perdre
au loin
on en a rêvé
que je n'ose plus
rendez le soleil y regarder le ciel
droit dans les yeux je n'y vois que du
feu je vous guiderai à l'extérieur de
votre tête je serai votre paire de
lunettes vous seriez monde
mais il me faut vous faire un aveu je
vous entends mais je ne pourrai jamais
vous reconnaître même assis entre deux
petits ville on se frotte à b1 contre
lettre à s'en faire cramer le squelette
et
l'âge de mon coeur à minuit pile on
prendre
pas même besoin d'ouvrir les yeux
je n'y vois que du feu
en quelques pas seulement je peux me
perdre loin si loin et même que je ne
peux plus regarder le soleil
ni à regarder le ciel
3dans
messieurs je n'y vois que du faux
tu te transforme souvent en glace à
l'italienne
seulement quand je mange des spaghettis
après minuit c'est quoi ce petit bruit
c'est la pluie vous aimez l'appui non
mais son bris oui et le bruit c'était
pas la foudre
jack au nom passa passa
qu'est ce que tu lui as fait